Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis continues to try to insert
words, including woke into his
lexicon. And he spoke in Iowa
because, remember, he is sort of like running for
president without actually announcing. And part
of that is that right now Florida law says you
have to resign the governorship to run. But the
Republicans are working on changing that law, as
I told you yesterday. So Ron DeSantis did an event
in Iowa and he tests out the word woke ocracy.
Speaker 2: Because woke ideology is infected.
So many institutions, if you really want to
protect the freedom of your folks, you've got
to be willing to defend them against the left,
imposing their pathologies on on your people in
any of these institutions. So we've got to fight
if we see it in medicine or the universities
or the corporations, you can't just say.
Unidentified: Let it go, because then we're
going to be living under an oppressive
woke ocracy and we can't that happen?
Speaker 1: We can't. That happens. So there
it is. Woke ocracy. Now, I have to tell you,
it's possible that someone who's more charismatic
would be able to deliver this woke ocracy thing
in a more functional way. That seems useful.
But there's another layer to this. And I talked
about this yesterday on the bonus show.
Woke is actually not seen that negatively
nationally. A new poll finds that 57% of Americans
still see Wokeness as a positive thing despite a
year long campaign by the right to pervert the
term which they've widely succeeded in doing.
But still, 57% of Americans see Wokeness as a
positive thing. So I know that it plays really
well in Republican circles and the whole thing.
But DeSantis may actually be overplaying his
hand when it comes to the obsession with Wokeness
and Florida's where Wokeness comes to die in the
whole thing. If he announces that he's running, we
will see where the woke stuff lands. I don't know
that Woke Ocracy is necessarily working. Woke is
stand, I think has a much better ring to it. But
who am I to give Ron DeSantis advice? Let's take a
quick break. We'll be back with more momentarily.